all right today we'll look at a critical
analysis of self supervision or what we
can learn from a single image by Yuki M
Asano Christine Ruprecht
and Andrea Vidal d this paper I really
was excited when I saw this paper
because the the outset is so cool and
the experiments have a very promising so
we'll take a look basically say we show
that three different and representative
methods baigan wrought net and deep
cluster so this is self supervision
techniques can learn the first few
layers of a convolutional network from a
single image as well as using millions
of images and manual labels provided
that strong data augmentation is used
however for deeper layers the gap with
manual supervision cannot be closed
even if millions of unlabeled images are
used for training we conclude that first
the weights of the early layers of deep
networks contain limited information
about the statistics of natural images
that second such low level statistics
can be learned through self supervision
just as well as through strong
supervision and that three the low level
statistics can be captured via synthetic
transformations instead of using large
image dataset
okay so I as I said I I was kind of
excited when I saw this and what they're
talking about is self supervision so
really quickly for those who don't know
self supervision is a technique where if
you have images but no labels and you
would still like to learn something from
them you can do you can do it a pre
training step for your network so
basically you have your neural network F
and what you would like to do is you
would like f of X to be close to Y for X
and Y 2 in your training data set but
you can if you have a much larger data
set of just XS right here you have pairs
of X&Y
of just x-u that are sort of similar to
the X in your in your label data set you
can do you can kind of get get your
network used to the data by doing this
self supervision so what you would do is
you would sort of come up with your own
labels for the data points and one way
is this will take just this rot net as a
example so what you'll do is you'll
input an image so maybe an image of the
number three in handwritten digit
recognition but you flip it you flip it
to its side right so it's the number
three right here and then you ask the
network to come up with an answer is it
upright is it flipped to the right is it
flipped to the left or is it turned on
its head which one is it and of course
you you who did the transformation know
the correct label all right so this is
how you come up with sort of fake labels
for your data and this works
surprisingly well and what this paper
basically says is that you do not
actually need this giant database here
it's actually sufficient sometimes if
you have one single image where you do
this on now the claim is a bit of a
cheat I have to say but we'll go into
that and further they say okay it's
enough to have one single images to
learn the features of the lower layers
of the neural network because they
usually tend to extract low-level
features that you know you can learn
from a single image but the higher level
of features you really need to supervise
data set you it's it's not enough to
have these self supervision techniques
and even if you have many many many self
supervision samples so if you actually
do have this giant data set it still
doesn't help you for the higher layers
almost causing to question this you have
a giant data set of unlabeled things
notion that is often presented including
by me okay so what do they do they do
they take
either single images are just very few
images so they also have a setting where
they take ten images for the single
image they hand select it so they hand
select the following three images so
this image right here they select
because it's very crowded there's a lot
going on right there's people there's
objects there is lighting and so on
there's um you know houses these lines
you know there's perspective so that's
why they select image a image be here
they also experiment with image B is a
drawn image as you can see there's also
lots of stuff going on but they
basically want to to research how does a
natural image compared to a artificial
image and then in see they have this is
sort of a control because there is lots
of parts here where it is not much going
on compared to here and most of the
image there's lots of stuff going on and
this image on the image number C letter
C has large areas where there's nothing
going on okay so these are the single
images now why I say it's a bit of a
cheat is that these images are actually
super large they four so for image net
and for C 410 they you know this might
be one of the samples of the C 410 or
image net classifier now of course C 410
is a lot smaller than image net but
still for image net these are you know
there are many pictures here not just
one so to say this is from a single
image it's it technically true but then
if you split it into multiple images
it's technically not true so it would
have been fun to see what actually
happens with a single image when you
downscale it but okay so how do they
investigate this there's this five layer
neural network right here so this five
convolutional I'm gonna guess there's
five convolutional layer after each
convolutional layer I think there is
some batch norm and relu then to the
next convolutional layer and so on
and then at the end maybe there is a or
there's also some pooling here max pool
at the end there is going to be some
linear classifier that classifies it
into either a ten or a hundred or a
thousand classes whatever you want the
way they investigate this is through
linear probes so called now linear
probes are somewhat of a somewhat of a
technique to inspect how much each of
the layers learn so if we again draw our
network right here and this is the input
X right so you have the hidden
representation one hidden representation
two hidden representation three and here
you output it to the Y hat and that you
compare with the Y from your data set
right the X is from your data set and
the Y's from your data set now a linear
probe wants to investigate how useful a
given hidden representation is to
classify the output so what a linear
probe would do is it would take the
hidden representation here and learn one
single linear classifier to classify
that hidden representation to come up
with a Y hat given h1 or something like
this so the important part here is that
this is linear right this is a this is a
linear classifier you do nothing more
you take the representation and instead
of this entire giant neural network on
top of it you simply build a linear
classifier and you can build these
linear probes from any layer right here
you can build a linear classifier on top
of this on the top of this and then you
basically look how good is your linear
classifier went when trained on that
hidden representation that the network
comes up with and that's how you
estimate how much information about the
target or let's say now how how optimal
the representation already is because at
the end of the network right you do have
a linear classifier so at some points
this representation must go into
form where it is now linearly
well classifiable and the assumption is
basically that these layers of the
neural network successively make a
representation that is more and more
linearly classifiable and that is a
strong assumption right and they this
this paper here uses linear probes
exclusively and that is a bit worrisome
to me because I have my troubles with
this linear probe approach because this
strong assumption that more linearly
classifiable is better it just rubs me
in the wrong way right we know that the
information content can never increase
from layer to layer about about the
label so any information about the label
that is an h1 sorry that is an h2 must
also have been present in h1 so
technically if we just built the correct
classifier we could predict from h1 just
as well as from h2 right because we're
actually doing it we're building the
neural network but the fact that we
cannot predict linearly as well using h1
so the fact that this classifier here
performs worse than this classifier here
because h1 is is a less optimal
representation in a linear sense it's
and it's just and the fact that I mean
yes but then to use that and to estimate
oh how useful is a representation you're
equating usefulness with linearly
classifiable and that I disagree a
representation can be extremely useful
if the following layers managed to do
something useful with it and that can be
something completely different or it can
even be the opposite of the linear
classifier bility right so this is kind
of my problem here and they don't do a
good work of convincing me otherwise so
they don't employ different technique
other than these linear probes in any
case when they do this linear probe you
can see right here that the percent
supervised performance so that's how
much how much percent of supervised
performance do you get so single single
image self supervision we show that
several self supervision methods can be
used to Train first few layers of a deep
neural networks using a single training
image such as this image a B or even C
provided that sufficient data plantation
is used so what they do here is they use
this self supervision then they take the
signal from the convolutional layer one
the hidden representation that's h1
right here they trained this linear
probe on it and they see how how well
does it perform after and this is after
the network has been self supervised
dwith rob net for example and then they
compare that to the linear probe at
layer one of the supervised Network
right so you take the supervised Network
and you do the same thing and there they
find okay this wrote net and all the
other techniques they perform very well
and especially if you only do a single
image they perform better as you can see
right here I mean if I interpret this
correctly this one rod net 1 by n1 deep
cluster these are these top things right
here and the 100 is the comparison to
the supervised performance right so 100
means 100 percent of the performance of
the supervised representation this is
absolutely crazy to me and this in fact
so let's just interpret it from their
perspective
right so you also have a random so if
you I guess if you randomly initialize a
network
then with the linear with training a
linear classifier on the hidden
representation one you could reach
something like 60% accuracy which is
impressive okay but if you do the linear
probe at layer two you reach a lower
accuracy now remember this is lower
accuracy compared to the supervised
performance right so the the there are
two effects at play here the supervised
performance is going to go up because
the well if you believe the assumption
that these successive layers make the
representation more and more linear for
linearly classifiable but also it could
be that just at the same time the self
supervised performance the performance
of the self supervised representation is
going down so the graph here is sort of
I don't really know how to interpret it
and it really goes down after that
that's why they say you can learn the
first layers fairly well with self
supervision even from a single image but
you cannot learn the upper layers and
they're basically just measuring this
using this linear probe method compared
to the supervised performance what I
would somewhat like to see is that you
train let's say you train a self
supervised network fine but then you
freeze this layer and then you fine-tune
the rest of your network on top of that
representation that would actually give
you an estimate of how useful is that
representation if I had an you know an
all-powerful function approximator which
is a neural network and then of course
you're probably not going to get
supervised performance and by the way
you'd have to compare that also to
supervised with and without pre-training
using self supervision and then you
actually get a good estimate of what how
well what can
a representation do these things learn
in this case all we you know all we get
out of this is this linear probe thing
compared to the supervised
representation and it just seems a bit
uninterpretable honestly and the fact
that here you can go beyond 100 percent
you can actually be better than
supervised should already tell you that
the linear this linear probe thing might
not be a good instrument too might not
be such a good instrument especially in
the lower layers the lower layers will
be most inaccurate with these linear
probe measurement but that's that's
they're finding basically they can learn
the features of the lower layers as well
in terms of this linear probe
formulation as the supervised learning
again they never compare this to fine
tuning on top of these representation or
compare it to self supervision plus
supervision which I would really expect
all right so they say they do a lots and
lots of data augmentations since of
course they only have a single image
they basically supercharge data
augmentation and they show that this
helps now I don't want to actually go
into the into the very into the very
details of what they're doing because
they just have different methods of
augmentation they just have different
networks but here are the results so if
this is on on image net if we use full
supervision we use the entire data set
and we do this linear probe evaluation
we get a twenty percent accuracy after
layer one thirty six after layer two and
so on
this goes up as we go through the layer
so this kind of gives credence to the
hypothesis that these layers sort of
make the representation more linear then
they have a bunch of scattering and
random network
and k-means pre-training which doesn't
get you a lot like but that's what they
compare it to basically the self
supervision to just the scattering
transforms and things like that but then
they get into their methods and here
we'll look at for example this rod net
so if you train on just one image this
image a of course if you have one image
then you get this many this this much of
the layer one now okay so now that I see
this here they have this column right
here which uses the full dataset what I
think this is is the self supervised
training using this many images so what
if you do wrought net self supervision
on this many it could also be the
performance after supervised training
after pre training with this method but
I think it is the performance after just
after self supervision again with no
fine-tuning on top and then evaluating
these linear probes that's why this
number is lower than this number right
here but astonishingly after you do it
with just one image you get a higher
number and if you do it with a thousand
images you get an even higher number but
if you do it with many more images you
do you you somehow don't get a higher
number this all seems a bit it seems a
bit weird honestly it basically means
that okay it is more important to
augment the same thing over and over and
over in different ways than it is to
incorporate different images I mean
there's ways I can believe that but I'm
not sure but you basically see that
after a while the performance compared
to the first of all to the supervised
method so yes if you look for example
here up here drops dramatically and even
if you have the full yawn now I'm
convinced that this this is just self
supervision using the full dataset even
if you have the full data set but only
do self supervision your performance
still suffers compared to the supervised
training so that's why they claim they
have these two claims you can learn the
first layer representations fairly well
with self supervision that's comparing
this number to this number you can do so
even from a single image that's
comparing this number to this number
right and noticing that it's almost the
same these two numbers are almost the
same actually one is a bit higher you
can learn that fairly well but if you go
down the layers you will basically
suffer with your single image and with
your full image soup self supervision so
you need to supervise signal to learn
the features of these later layers and
that's all evaluated with these linear
probe things yeah so that is their main
claims right here and they kind of
analyze image a and image B so they come
to the conclusion that image a works
much better because it's natural and
image B is not working so well but this
depends on the self supervision used and
image C still apparently works quite
well even though it has these large
areas of nothing which all of this is a
bit weird but it's definitely cool to
see these results now again I would like
to see something like you freeze these
representations and then you actually
train a neural network on top of that
and look how that
performs that would actually be an
interesting thing though maybe they've
done this and I'm just unaware right
here they look at the filters that these
methods have learned just from self
supervision on a single image and you
can see these are the types of filters
that we would see using even supervised
learning if you look at the filters they
turn out to look pretty much like this
of course I can't decide if these
particular things are good or bad
filters or not they do some qualitative
analysis and here they have fine tuning
okay fine tuning experiments the pre
trained models first to convolutions are
left frozen or replaced by the
scattering transform and the network is
retrained using imagenet training set
okay here we go so if you do this fully
supervised you get to a fifty nine point
four now okay this seems very low
accuracy honestly for even like for
imagenet but maybe this is their thing
but if they do this on top of the on top
of the these self supervised methods
they do get a fairly good okay they get
a fairly good accuracy right here I
would have liked to have this evaluation
right here be applied in the table above
and not these linear probes they just
seem kind of kind of wonky but you can
see that it is possible to learn this to
learn this using just a single image to
learn the features of the lower layers
now how you exactly would would put this
into a training procedure how you
exactly make use of this during training
if you already know that it's not gonna
help for the deeper layers I'm not so
sure we
because at least you always have your
own data set right so you always have at
least that many images that you can self
supervise train on but it's certainly
interesting interesting results and with
that I think I'm going to leave it at
that and thanks for listening I hope you
enjoyed this and bye bye